we might be drunk
we might be drunk
as long as we are hanging out you know
we might be drunk raise a glass let's
talk [ __ ] head peeps wrecks and a bit
maybe drunk
we might be drunk
yeah
guys welcome to a special valentine's
episode but where's mark
oh look at that
happy half valentines happy valentines
folks good to be here i love i look like
liberace you look like a gay julius
caesar yes that's me i love it a2 anal
all right i love it look at this you're
like this is like uh this is a very
revealing outfit i know it's a lot of
nip i'm sorry but uh they don't make
heterosexual sizes
there we go what uh
i love it though the nip is just out
yeah this is like the elaine christmas
card episode
i think i see
it is
oh yeah
the nip slip the nip slip yeah you look
like uh hugh hef over here hugh hefner
well you're right liberace
what's the other guy's name
who oh wayne newton getting ready to pop
here all right get ready here we go
whoo
you look like if the devil went clubbing
come on there we go hey
happy valentines i'm not a big champagne
guy i haven't popped one of these in a
while well you know you just you can
just sip it
it's uh it's a holiday made by the
corporations it is the [ __ ] over
boyfriends
isn't it annoying oh yeah that's silly
what do we get on valentine's day i know
michael chad that great joke he's like i
buy you flowers dinner and you blow me
he's like you should be blowing me on a
tuesday
you know it's a good point
weird that it's a holiday thing
and the cupid what a strange yeah
cherubic little boy you know what he
looks like a little bit a little baby
with a a bow and arrow kind of looks
like a like the poster child for like
anti-abortion
but he's like you get the [ __ ] out of
here right right
yeah there he is
cheers
this is a this is a real episode for the
ladies i mean look at this we do it for
you girls we love the gish there we are
there's a lot of boyfriends right now
going what the [ __ ] am i gonna do i
gotta do something i didn't get
reservations i didn't get a gift the
chocolate the flowers it's a lot of work
the anti-native american you didn't get
reservations
yeah my my gal admitted that she said um
valentine's day is fun
we just want to know you struggled a
little i'm like it's not about the
flower you just want to know it was a a
[ __ ] to do commitment
well you want but you want to see like
we had to work hard to get you a gift
yeah we had to go on 800 flowers pick
the [ __ ] put the card number in do all
that they really raised the prices that
i mean it's like hilarious it's like
every other day 10 delivery for you like
valentine's day 97
yeah what the hell did that come from i
know and i think
you know these you see these bodegas in
new york all they have outdoors are
these flowers flowers there's so many
and who's buying those they must die
weekly right you show up with like the
the gift wrapping paper around the
flowers she knows you [ __ ] up oh yeah
if they're if they're not in a nice
little voice and they always upsell you
they're always like oh you get a little
teddy bear for an extra seven dollars
yes that's true what is she 14 well the
thing is they're all at the office and
then you get the flowers the girl next
to gets the flower and the teddy bear
you're [ __ ] well now that everyone's
working from home
no more flowers that's true and the
little guatemalan guy working at the
bodega you know whenever you buy flowers
you're in trouble you know but that's
the one day he's like i got a better
life than you
you're buying these flowers he's like ah
you're in the doghouse
sure i live in a shoebox but
i'm i'm playing video games tonight
you know it's uh
and it's a weird holiday because it is i
do feel like women when they when
they're not in a relationship on
valentine's day do get upset you get the
two sides you get the empowered like i'm
going out tonight or you get the i'm low
right you know and it's kind of like nah
it's like it's a [ __ ] holiday you
don't have to feel that way it really is
it's the jewish christmas you know it's
the same thing but
what does that mean well i think jews on
christmas are like this isn't really our
thing but i love christmas
okay well there you go because you know
i it's a nice time of year you i like
christmas music sure and then on top of
that you get a day of basketball and on
top of that
it's like a traditional order in chinese
so i have i have fondness for christmas
all right i like that yeah
we don't feel anything on a hanukkah
are you guys aware of uh february 13th
being the day for the gummad
that makes sense
the mistress yep damn that's hilarious
that's gonna [ __ ] you though on
valentine's because they're gonna be
like
they're gonna be so mad they're gonna
call the house you know and carmelo's
gonna pick up
it is hilarious to give them the off
night yeah i mean there's it's not even
nice you're like oh you you get the uh
you get to be the b team
does that even feel good jv that's tough
but i will say for guys valentine's day
if you're single you hit the bar you're
getting laid yeah because they're these
gals are just like i need some kind of
companionship some something some
connection there's there's definitely
like wedding crashers energy in the air
yes you do feel like you're like a
groomsman or something and uh yeah i
mean it's
it is a crazy night out yeah for sure as
a single guy and no matter how empowered
you are feminist the loner whatever i
you feel it
every commercial is is you know every
kiss begins with k
and then you're at home eating uh bon
bons and watching uh ozark again
i gave up on ozark i'm kind of like oh
the new season's cooking it's good ah
i'm already four in i almost was late to
this really yeah you can't watch tv in
the day it's just a it's a poison yeah
it's not a night it's like drinking in
the day it is anyway
[Laughter]
remember these little [ __ ] chalk
candies that everybody had let me see
what someone says
you have hpv what the hell wow they've
changed yeah
what the damn it
what'd you get
trans aren't real what the hell is going
on here what are these things these are
terrible i know these are so bad they're
horrible you're eating chalk you're
eating chalk this is just chalk i think
they're like 80 cents a gallon
there's no i just bit into this this
there's no nutrition no whatever this is
going in yeah no flavor no nutrition and
look the words are all askew what'd you
get the cheap box geez look at that the
take me is written on just his tack
what uh how do you feel about uh
how do you feel about champagne both of
you guys gal pal i could leave it you
could lit too sweet it's too sweet too
sweet i like bitter alcohol i don't yeah
i don't oh like i like wine i like
smokey i like yeah like sweet smoky
bitter yeah
i don't know i like it maybe it's just
the accoutrements you know it's it's at
a party it's the popping it's the fizzy
because you associate it with festive
right
but it's kind of like lobster where we
put it out in this high pedestal but
it's not really that great yeah it used
to be peasant food lobster exactly yeah
champagne is but i guess you associated
with like a wedding so i associate with
it uh having to buy a plane ticket to
something mm-hmm
oh good point that makes sense you're
not drinking champagne at a funeral yeah
unless you hate the guy we should
normalize that yeah that's good
like send them off right them off yeah
it's better i i you know what i loved on
the wire when someone would die and
they'd lay the body on the on the pool
table in the bar and they just get
hammered i love that
the irish man yeah the irish do it right
they do anything alcohol related they do
right uh except find a place to sleep
that night other than that
and potatoes
yeah yeah and also uh this this is i
associate champagne with marriage which
is terrifying
i'll see you in november honey all right
wedding's coming up
can't believe it i know
how do you feel well the clock's ticking
but this is it this is my my moment this
is like before uh you know they take you
in
yeah you got to live vegas atlantic city
champagne drinking
cupid
you gotta live now so you popped a big
question
now the next question is do you allow
kids at your wedding no
no kids
we're having an abortion booth
no kids at the wedding
i i think that's a fun idea i thought
the pictures were kind of odd the little
uh strip
nothing
people do that at the weddings right you
get the picture yeah one two three four
the face all right i don't know why i'm
explaining the joke that bombed here
yeah yeah no kids cause it's not just we
don't like kids yeah we don't
but
you got them uh the parents now can't
have fun because they're watching the
kids so it takes away from the whole
environment yeah same with a comedy show
you don't want kids at a comedy show you
can't [ __ ] around
yeah and if you do [ __ ] around you kind
of have to work the kid into it you have
to be like this guy he doesn't he
doesn't know he doesn't know what
fisting is look at this kid
you
hope
yeah exactly yeah so we want it to be uh
it's new orleans it's you know fun in
the sun it's gonna be great i'll say
i'll say this about new orleans new
orleans is like
the tasteful city of sin oh
cause vegas everyone but it's like the
commercial city of sin yes you still
have uh legalized gambling you got that
right in new orleans you got haras and
stuff you've got uh
it's just more fun yeah and we you know
we have is the culture vegas is just
like here's our stripper strip club we
got steaks we got slot machines we got
high rollers in new orleans is like we
got jazz we got creole food we got jazz
fest we got mardi gras we got the french
quarter you know we got the good food
it's got that mixed in you're right it
has more of an identity history history
yeah the french you know creole and then
you have like actual music as opposed to
some guy who's doing like a robert
goulet impression like
yeah there's a reason vegas is is dj
tiesto you know we got whit marsalis
yeah they got some uh hack on a laptop
for sure easy
[Laughter]
techno's not real music
they know that yeah i'm not i'm not into
vegas i don't like no i'm with you and i
like reno even less
what do you like about vegas what comes
out of vegas that you're like i like
once you're off the strip it's all right
like there's a lot of beautiful stuff in
vegas but that strip just like i don't
know and it's like
you you stay in a hotel in there you
could stay in for like five days and not
go outside there's a darkness
oh big dark big dark but the rat pack
energy is great that whole branding was
good night one in vegas is great night
one's great the hangover and then it's
all downhill yeah well you see people
walking into vegas there's so much hope
you see them leaving you're just like oh
man that's that dude needs help well
when the hangover kicks in and the sun
is shining and you look around you hear
that bing bing bing bing there's smoke
everywhere she's on a rascal he's on a
respirator they're drinking a gin and
tonic smoking at 11 a.m you hit the
buffet then you hate yourself then you
go to the pool and the c-section scars
the neck tattoos i gotta stop saying
it's circus circus i remember i was at a
shitty casino in uh
in reno nevada my opening line was uh
man what a great city if you ever want
to see fake tits and an oxygen tank on
the same person
i mean but i remember uh combine them
well i was at the uh i was at the
all-you-can-eat buffet and i saw jim
jeffries he like came to hang out and we
uh and i was like man that's all you can
eat buffet goes when you make enough
money everything's an all you can eat
that's a baller line man he's always
charming
[Laughter]
he's very there's like a poetry to the
way he speaks complete well he's i love
that mix of degenerate booze bag you
know piece of [ __ ] guy with like
intellect and and wit
dude he he uh
the way he speaks is very funny like i
saw him years ago his opening form and
he uh the way he dealt with the heckler
he just go he says the word [ __ ] and it
doesn't feel off-putting yeah he goes
you're gonna wake up tomorrow and you're
gonna think i was a bit of a [ __ ]
and that's the only time you're right
and he's got a smile the whole time in a
cocktail it just works yeah the accent
goes a long way classic he's a classic
although it wouldn't really work with
like would that work with an indian
accent
i don't know if you're charming enough
you could probably pull it off in any
accent but for some reason the brits and
the aussies can really get away with the
c word they're they really they really
there's something softer about them
saying that yeah
they're not talking about women's
private parts they're talking about a
personality type yeah but who actually
refers to a vagina as a [ __ ] i've never
heard anybody go i'm gonna [ __ ] in the
[ __ ] a hell's angel maybe yeah exactly
who does that sounds very violent yeah
i've never heard of a [ __ ] talking about
the the clam
it's almost like calling a guy's penis a
hog
you're like that's weird like look at
that hog for a woman i mean oh a woman a
woman yes yes a woman yeah they never
say that a guy will say it jokingly but
a woman won't say that no not to me
especially
i got no hog
i heard an interview with jim jeffries
and he was talking about his last
special on netflix and they said uh look
do whatever you want just don't say [ __ ]
within the first 15 minutes so we don't
lose the audience he goes if you watch
the special at 15 minutes and four
seconds i'm like ah you [ __ ]
we hit a [ __ ] clock up in the corner
that's hilarious
damn that's what i call my my wife's
cycle
all right
i fluffed it damn it
we got it now i used to all right
man i don't like champagne
it's like does nothing for me i get wine
like if i'm if we're drinking like uh
like a smoky red i'll i'll [ __ ] get
on board if like we're drinking like a a
pd
scotch or something by the way guys if
you're listening
we might have good news on the on the
whiskey that's coming up ah a lot of you
been asking
it's
this [ __ ] takes a long time a lot of red
tape a lot of fine prints mark and i
have never been a place where we've had
lawyers
and apparently that's why a lot of
people owe us money the last few years
we are not good businessmen good point
but uh the good news is we have lawyers
now who are making sure we don't get
[ __ ] and i think
i think this is i mean we've already
tried it's great whiskey great it's
gonna take off and we and so many of you
guys are asking us about it on the road
that i feel like we're gonna sell out
man oh yeah now here's the question yeah
let's hype this thing up let's let's
move some product can we reveal the new
name let's wait to see if it's if it's
uh
if it's of a go if there's a copyright
issue yeah like yeah we have a new name
it's a cool name at the very bottom
this is big yeah it's big and i i think
more of a tease in that outfit right
there
look at that nipple
i
wish
yeah you could do it i don't know how to
do it come on you could do it yeah i got
nothing is it homoerotic if i'm
attracted to it yeah you've got a nice
name yes look at that solid nip there's
like eight hairs coming out of it if i
look if i had to suck on a man's nipple
that wouldn't be the last one i chose
all right i'll take it right peters is
in the booth giving a thumbs up too i'm
not crazy look as a straight man it's
important to say you know
i'm not i'm not ashamed of my sexuality
and i'm not ashamed if hey if i were gay
who gives a [ __ ] i'm just saying i'm
looking at that nipple and i'm saying
well done all right that's all i'm
saying i look like the guy in 300 who
couldn't get in i'm like oh guys
i'm just cleaning swords
[Laughter]
do you shave your chest no i'm just
naturally not a hairy douche and my
[ __ ] looks like your eyebrows
but uh you're like you're like the mr
bigglesworth of cats here what the hell
i'm like i'm like a [ __ ] rag doll
over here yeah well i i'd kill for a
half between a halfway because my lady's
always like i wish i had a little more
chest hair really yeah she likes it ugh
i know
i mean i hate it as a kid i remember i
dated a girl in college and she was like
can you shave your chest it's kind of
gross and i was a kid yeah i remember
yeah and i remember as a kid being like
yeah sure all right and then i grew up
i'm like oh i can't believe i let her do
that to me i felt violated and that's a
little imagine say that to a woman like
hey could you lose five pound or
whatever it is like what's the
difference i have said that
[Laughter]
no no i but i think uh you know
yeah the chest hair thing it's like you
grow up and you're kind of like it's
fine it is funny when you see an actor
take off his shirt in a movie and he's
hairy and you're like oh wow he's human
yeah it's normal you're just so used to
seeing like ryan goss right bodies or
brad pitt where it's just like perfect
yeah so when you see like a sean connery
you're like [ __ ] yeah dude yeah baldwin
my dad alex baldwin yeah very hairy he
stopped going shirtless though at a
certain point
yeah you know yeah yeah that's true he
also stopped checking the gun but
but my dad is insanely hairy i'm talking
shoulder hair yeah that's my dad looks
like that and the only downside i didn't
mind i didn't give a [ __ ] but the only
downside was when we'd go to like the
rec center and he'd be in the pool and
i'd be like swimming towards him and it
would be that
you know hair wiggle water and that was
a little like ah it's drenched it's
dripping exactly yeah like [ __ ]
tassels on a stripper's nipple totally
just the hair drip yeah there's
something something weird about those
rec centers they make you wear the hair
uh thing right you have to wear the do
that the swimming
but they don't do anything about this
they don't make me wear like a full body
scuba suit or the pubes but my god the
pubes yeah do you have a pube situation
full bush really i go full really oh
yeah i'm all natural
landscape sponsored by oh [ __ ]
yeah if i do hit the bass i look better
but i just yeah i don't know i feel
weird doing it what about you yeah i'm
hairy yeah i'm hairy all over i'm a
hairy guy
there you go you're russian
polish russian polish russian yeah do
you get the leg
i'm hairy to me that's the ugly part
because you want the genitals to really
pop
but if the the hair goes onto the thigh
i feel like the whole thing is a little
more it's not like horrible but i look
like i probably
i look like that without the tone right
right right i'm not playing uh uh jack
ryan in hunt for red october you know
what i mean but i do yeah i'm hairy now
where are you at on the back hair i got
a little up top down low or all over
just a little up top okay just a little
hint like a little cherry on top of the
sundae i think that's gross it's gross
yeah like just the patches on the
shoulder yeah it's not good wow i don't
feel good about it if it's a hint it's a
hint yeah i think a hint's okay do you
are you not hairy uh yeah
not not like this or not like you but
somewhere all right all right i've never
showed up right now yeah please i
remember i was really high as a kid once
and uh we were at a girl's house and she
uh we were so all so baked and she uh
she pulled up a picture of a really
hairy guy's ass and i was so high that i
was like is that me
uh
she goes what and i was like i'm just is
that my ass and she's like no it's like
it's a website that's hilarious and i
was just like i was just and she was
like this is like crazy that you think
that's and i was like oh all right well
you were that high yeah yeah that's
hilarious
who gave you that picture of my ass
this is this is the worst valentine's
day episode ever we're talking about ass
and ball hair we've lost every female
listener oh yeah
oh that this that's that's stuff well
that's part of why the uh
40 year old virgin scene was such a big
hit with steve carell right because
she's waxing him
but like he was a hairy dude oh yeah
oh yeah very hairy that was big that was
real hair i assume oh jeez look at that
butt we can't use any of this can't we
yeah it's a butt side butt that's fine
side butt you always feel like you're
gonna look way better without the hair
here you always think once you shave
you're like i'm gonna look like [ __ ]
hugh jackman dude and then you look at
it you're like
i wonder if he had to uh you know get
really waxed on film oh i think that's
his first waxing ever yeah so that's
real i think it must be because some
blood pops up and she does it over the
nipple too that's gonna hurt so [ __ ]
badly
women do this [ __ ] all the time by the
way that's true
and they get the labia [ __ ] wax that
is a sensitive area
so this is just how funny carell is he's
just riffing
in pain literally so i got a theory
about the scene i know no one asked but
uh i can't remember what the actor's
name is the black actor yeah he's great
he walks out and says i can't i can't
watch any more of this and i have a
feeling he does it right here right here
and i have a feeling like they were
shooting this and there was a continuity
problem i don't know this to be true
because why would you remove an actor
from a scene
huh
[Music]
this was his breakout role man oh yeah
this and the office i know right were
they simultaneous running simultaneously
i think so yeah
well they said this bombed and the
office saved the tickets
piston this movie did not bomb they said
it kind of got fizzled away then the
office was such a hit that people fell
alone give it a goog
that's great man
this is like young apatow everybody's
young and and full of life seth rogen
was fun holy [ __ ]
[Laughter]
it's crazy paul rudd just looks exactly
the same
so he leaves so i think there's a
continuity problem because they do this
next one and he's not there yep they
can't explain it like why is he not
there
all right see they fix it i don't know
if it's fixed i mean i think they
wow
she's just laughing this is
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
this is like the classic seinfeld but
how women will will you know pour the
flaming hot wax on rip it off from the
root but you're still scared of a spider
that's a classic classic bit so true the
labia is so delicate and they just
it's crazy i mean can't be that delicate
yeah i guess you're doing that to it i
must toughen it up that was the old
betty white quote why do we call a
vagina a [ __ ] it takes a pounding keeps
coming back is that betty white that's
betty white give it a go i thought it
was tick not han that's crazy
who also just died
95. wow i heard it was because of the
covet vaccine
i heard it was funny that's what uh dr
hulk hogan told me
he said that the covet vaccine is why uh
betty white and sydney podiu died in
their 90s
hulk hogan huh
show me a pro wrestler who lived past
87.
and you're giving medical advice why do
people say you grow balls balls are weak
and sensitive you grow get tough grow a
vagina
damn so
respect respect betty white yeah it
makes you realize like she could really
get ruffled up in bed i guess yeah
damn oh yeah
good for her
what are there any rom-coms that like
you're okay with because rom-coms are
obviously a woman's game that genre but
there are some that transcend the genre
right yeah annie hall annie hall killer
but guess what you say any hall they
don't end up together ah
that's like a socially acceptable male
rom-com they broke the mold because i
was gonna say like you know annie hall
is like one of my top two yeah
what else is good what's a good rom-com
about a love actually is good but it's
christmas more than valentine's probably
um
high fidelity oh great one great one
when harry met sally oh yes now we're
cooking
uh something about mary does that count
that's not that's like a comedy that has
you know a love interest sure
all right
he's great woman sucks
uh moonstruck is funny i have never seen
moonstr moonstruck nicholas cage is
great man all right sleepless is all
right
you've got mail is fine it's funny that
he's like the big bookstore and that's
the villain back then he's like yeah
this guy works for the barnes noble
equivalent and it's like now it's like
they're just getting destroyed yeah yeah
whenever whenever i'm in a barnes and
noble it has the same feeling
as like when you're visiting a
grandparent where you're like ah this
doesn't have long you know that's true
it's a bummer you love it and yeah and i
love a bookstore on the road too go
through books on the road so nice city
lights in san francisco you ever been
there oh my god i was just there i
bought a couple film noir books
they've got so much good stuff
yeah it's nice but you're right the
barnes noble is like grandmas because
you go in there you're bored you just
sit down and then you're like you just
sit for an hour just waiting to for time
to pass you like i shouldn't look at my
phone but i will yeah yeah you read
man shout out to the bookstore
it's like a little safe haven you're on
the road you just run in there like this
is this is perfect it really is they're
always quiet you even feel a little
cooler and smarter being in there like
powell's books in portland you just walk
through there i'm not going to buy a
goddamn thing i pretend to look at one
i'm like oh get out of here then i put
it back you know we all do it
and we go oh that's good and he never
read it but you heard it was you've
heard of it that's just it did you guys
mention harry met sally yeah that's a
great one yeah
i mean it is hilarious i think gary
goldman has a joke about this about how
like he's just like not into her he's
like the balding womanizer
you know
billy crystal's like slow down meg ryan
you know like they bang and he's like
i've got a lot of poon to work through
in new york cause uh
uh i mean shout out to bruno kirby too
and carrie fisher who are both passed
away who are both amazing and great
great rom-com rob reiner crushed it man
crushed it and going through a divorce
while making it wow yeah which like
totally [ __ ] him up he said
damn and of course the iconic that's his
deli scene i got a shout out richmond
virginia has a jewish deli um pearlies
that gary veeder and i ate at one of the
best meals in my life man really i mean
the borscht the the matzo ball we got
smoked salmon bagels the pickles just
like a classic it's incredible like
they were all like i was like where did
we go and
um they looked at both of you in
richmond
they said it's like the spot bourdain
went there the man versus food guy like
it was like this is our spot i think if
you're the jewish place in west virginia
you're like we gotta kill it you know
you gotta bring the heat
like jackie robinson
oh that does look good
oh wow that looks great dude it was
incredible i love a jewish deli
and the big portions too dude it was
great all right yeah and i love the old
look with the boots and the font and the
tile walls look at that i bet they got
some head shots in there
that's the other jewish joke man this
place is terrible and the portions oh
yeah that's great that's so small yeah
that's so good well the waiter goes up
to the guy and he goes is anything all
right
classic classic so many jewish jokes are
just like i'm miserable
that's like the punchline like i'm
unhappy yes exactly
damn yeah i love uh i love that place we
went that we here's the thing we wanted
to go back the next day but they comped
our meal
they comped our meal like gary and i
were like we got to go back i'm like we
can't go back because now they're gonna
think we just want another free meal and
i i don't want to do that that's so
curved but that's like such a great plot
in seinfeld or curb why because we were
both like dying to go back it was so
good yeah back in disguise right right
full rabbit
i had a similar thing i told you this
story but i went by a restaurant with
with me and my lady and this guy was
like came out of the restaurant at the
apron on he's like oh i'm a fan you i
love your comedy i was like oh he's like
anytime you want come by here let me
know and it was a full restaurant i was
like all right and she was like let's go
back tonight i was like great he'll
still remember us we go back we buy all
the [ __ ] all these drinks you gotta have
this you gotta have that
they didn't compass i remember you told
me when this happened this is so [ __ ]
funny yeah it's insane to upsell you yes
after being like i'll take care of you
that's not taking care of you no we all
know what take care of means exactly so
we we made a sketch about it there it is
but uh i remember this was beautifully
shot yeah that's sally for he's fun man
this is a good stage that's my manhattan
this is uh he's now dating his son
stepson but
we so we uh
we talked about i remember mark did a
club back in the day and they up sold
him on like mark said what do i eat here
yeah i get the salmon right funny farm
in youngstown ohio
and they upsell mark on the salmon and
then they charged him mark's like i'll
get a burger like now get the salmon yep
and then they charged it happened to me
at a club called loonies in colorado
springs really well they were like the
bartender all week was like you have a
beer like ah man i don't know i'm going
on he said come on have a beer [ __ ] and
i was like ah [ __ ] it i have a fish so i
had a few beers each night and at the
end of the week they gave me a bill damn
what a funny way to upsell
you [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
damn
yeah i waited tables for years that that
upsell [ __ ] is real that's [ __ ]
[ __ ] we got a new wine in this is
how you sell it blah blah blah it'll
make your bill go from here to here
which makes your tip go from here to
here and like guys took that [ __ ]
serious like wall street
alcohol it's all alcohol what's the deal
with um
the sec the second most expensive bottle
of wine is what the guys always order
right isn't there something like about
that that makes sense because you're not
crazy breaking the bank but it's still
high-end well you're like well it's not
the cheapest but i don't want to what am
i you know if it's like 18 if there's
like a like a 16 bottle of wine a 19
bottle of wine
you know
a 40 and a 45. what do you what's your
high goat 40.
no in my head i'm like i go like 19
probably oh 50 seconds 40 45 so i went
40. oh yeah yeah but i see what you're
saying that makes sense that's all
psychology you know the 99 cents thing
is just a dollar but you see 99 less
than a dollar you buy it yeah damn
prostitute should coverage uh 399.
[Laughter]
yeah exactly
or 299.99 i guess is the real move sure
depending on the pros dude you ever
gotten one no i can't do that [ __ ] yeah
do you do it i did it once but you were
a kid that was a virginity she didn't
charge and i didn't know she was a
prostitute
she didn't charge a terrible prostitute
well i think we had a good time which is
what every guy told me well he has proof
that stripper liked me this one's on the
house yeah
well i was also illegal
so maybe she didn't want to have any uh
detachment you were you were molested i
guess i'm a survivor but it was great
mark's bragging right now i think this
is like not good well i was underage
legally but i guess for guys it is
different sure i know that's what that's
not what the police report ever says
how old were you 16. that's [ __ ]
young yeah if you even said like 17 or
18 but like 16 is [ __ ] young but was
she in her 30s do you know
older she was what late 40 pushing 50.
she's giving away you say something like
that i'm worried about you every week
i don't have health insurance i steal
i had sex with an old woman when i was a
teenager i never told you this you've
told me but i know you were 16. oh yeah
and her husband was there
or pimp
who knows i didn't check ids jesus
christ i'm sure they're dead
i mean they were not looking great she
died of old age yeah yeah i think so it
was betty white
no they're definitely done he had a
harley davidson jacket on she was very
weathered
damn yeah yeah you never want to hear
whether it is an adjective about
yourself when you're a woman you don't
ever want to she's what you like she's
kind she's homely she's weathered yeah
yeah exactly
she was rough seeing a lot of winters uh
she'd been around
she was a
hacker a lot of winters in louisiana
well she's been all over who knows where
i'd love to see her again if she's alive
reach out sister yes
she's a fan of the podcast
it's like pearly's like come on one more
free round here i would compare it to
kellyanne conway similar look oh that's
not bad no no not bad not bad but when
you're 16 that looks like the [ __ ]
keeper you know sure
here's a picture of the pimp and the
hooker huh
is that stephen dorff
um yeah what happened to steven dorf he
was just in uh something he's like in a
fighter movie right yeah yeah i saw him
interviewed or something he was like the
guy in the 90s i remember he's in that
nicholson movie blood and wine
like blade right that's right right
he was like the new door uh rourke but
he just
like three years ago he's doing like
blue jewel yeah
yeah i remember that like fake
cigarettes whatever that was yeah that's
hilarious they're in a room they're like
who who's a celebrity who can get who's
believable with a jewel and they're like
stephen door
let's lay off work early guys we nailed
it
they should have gotten jewel
i mean it's right there
i mean the fact that you can like get
ahead in the world and your last name is
dorf it's quite impressive he's handsome
he's handsome and cool but like dwarf
well we grew up with the dwarf videos
dwarf on golf doors
yes i never realized that until this
very moment there you go the dwarf is
just burnt in his joke silly stuff
advertising's so weird like that eminem
thing where they're like we're gonna be
more inclusive and everyone you know
what's amazing everyone's [ __ ] on it
but i'm like they're geniuses exactly
like literally tucker carlson's like
okay eminem's and then whoopi gold was
like eminem's like literally every
person's talking about it and people
like this i was so stupid i'm like no
they know what they're doing dude potato
head nailed it first they started it and
you're right everybody's talking about
how stupid it is people get all like
picket fence-y with this [ __ ]
well the far right is like
in my day eminem were were more [ __ ]
and then you know and then you get the
far left like well it's time to be
inclusive with it and you're just like
everyone's got an opinion yeah opinion
equals posts exactly exactly it's like
the new york post how all their their uh
tons well they're puns but they're also
like they're clickbaity they're like yes
like what happened when this person said
this and you're like but they didn't
really say that but you click on it
that's great woke mob remove snickers
dick vane that's [ __ ] quality
brilliant who came up with that that's
everybody on reddit that is quality it
does have a vein it does it's a black
[ __ ] with a big vein down the middle
damn
look at that there it is that looks like
my dick
not the color but the
vein and my dick is very square
filled with nougat but yeah
that's fun that's amazing the internet
is undefeated do you see that one delta
i i some guy [ __ ] nailed this i love
just a one quick zigger delta wrote
what's uh what's a city that changed
your life you know like travel [ __ ] and
one guy wrote wuhan and i'm like oh
that's a great country or whatever it is
but man that was gold yeah
that's funny as hell and i love the guy
all the people in the boardroom are like
all right we want to put out a nice pose
how can this be offend there's no way
they can find anything to joke about
here or be offended here and they still
got one they need to hire comments to
look at their tweets before they post
them ah like a focus group yes
just a bunch of incel looking dudes in a
room like i would say this about my dick
and i'm like all right pull it
out
exactly
we might be drunk as excited to welcome
our new sponsor
diet smoke
most of us have had a i don't think this
edible is working moment then 10 minutes
later you're on the couch and you can't
remember the word cat i've been there
edibles can hit you when you least
expect it and their dosage can be very
uncertain that's why when we need the
perfect medium high we hit our friends
at diet smoke for the delicious
delta 8 thc gummies
each gummi is infused with 10 milligrams
of delta 8 thc derived from american
grown health hemp delta 8 is simply a
slightly less potent thc the high you
get with diet smoke is somewhere between
the chilledness of cbd and that classic
stone feeling you get with regular weed
plus diet smoke comes in two delicious
favorite flavors blue raspberry and
watermelon i've been taking this stuff
to go to bed you know me i can't get
high i go inward i hug my knees i think
of my dad i cry
this stuff is top notch it's just what i
need it's like having a light beer yeah
you heard her dad does the same thing he
gets on his knees he thinks of you he
cries it's
all because this stuff right here that's
how i got in this mess mess
oh geez
it's legal in most states and
non-prescription just check diet smokes
website to see if they ship to your
state also their gummies are low in
sugar fat free and delish so when cbd
isn't enough and traditional thc is too
much enjoy the smooth buzz of diet smoke
that's diet smoke.com use promotional
code drunk for 20 off your order that's
dietsmoke.com promo code drunk 20 off as
a special offer diet smokes coupon code
can be used on every order
so give it a shot come back
say like yeah i'm doing this again 20
off again diet smokes delta 8 thc
gummies are not for use or sale to
people under the age of 21 please use
responsibly diet smoke isn't light
it's just right
we might be drunk and sponsored by
better help online therapy just like
going to the gym or the dentist we
should be caring for our mental health
as much as our physical health going to
therapy doesn't mean something's wrong
with you it means that you know that
people have emotions and we all need
help controlling them sometimes we're
both in therapy we have the same [ __ ]
therapist you got me in changed my life
take out the mental garbage it's all
piling up nobody's perfect we all have a
[ __ ] up childhood it's all still with
us
figure out who you are learn about
yourself and you can get better it's the
only way to get better and tell them how
well there's a mental health crisis in
this city too right now people if you
can afford it and this is affordable so
i say give it a shot if you can uh
better help is customized customized
online therapy that offers video phone
and even live uh chat sessions with your
therapist show them to see anyone on
camera if you don't want to it's much
more affordable than in-person therapy
and you can start communicating with
your therapist in under 48 hours give it
a try and see why over 2 million people
have used better help online therapy
this podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
and you get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
drunk that's better help
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com
drunk hell yeah
hey we might be drunk folks we are
brought to you by draftkings sport book
the moment we've been waiting for since
september is finally here in honor of
the big game draftkings sports book an
official sports betting partner of super
bowl 56 is giving new customers 56 to
one odds on either team come on
bench is five dollars and get 280
in free bets if your team wins draftking
sportsbook is now live in new york
meaning you can bet from almost a third
of the country whoa
if sportsbook isn't in your state yet
play draftkings daily fantasy football
contest for super bowl 56
new customers can get a free shot at a
one million dollar top prize with their
first surprise and tell them how savage
download the draftkings sportsbook app
use promo code wmbd
and get 56 to one odds on either team
bet just five dollars and get 280 in
free bets if your team wins that's promo
code wmbd
at draftking sportsbook an official
sports betting partner of super bowl 56
21 and over minimum age and location
requirements vary by jurisdiction see
draftkings.com
sportsbook i love jurisdiction yeah it's
a fun it's like you think of an fbi guy
this is our jurisdiction right you know
it's kind of fun that is nice full list
of requirements and state-specific
responsible gaming resources void we're
prohibited gambling problem call 1-800
gambler we got to say this i guess in
tennessee call or text at tn redline uh
1-800-889-9789
in connecticut do we have to say all
this stuff call 888-789-7777
chat in new york call 8778
hope and why or text hope and why a lot
of side effects here folks be careful
but it's fun to bet on sports so yeah
support the show by downloading the
draftkings sportsbook app and use promo
code wmbd get 56 to one odds on either
team
all right what do you got on a wreck
i don't i have more peeves this weekend
oh although i will say okay
so i'm running like five minutes late
this week and i [ __ ] hustle to make
it not 10.
you know i hate being late i hate i i
pride myself on being punctual it's
important to me
uh i think it's like a thing of respect
so i apologize that i was five minutes
late on top of that i'm late because all
these [ __ ] orders now at starbucks or
chipotle or wherever you go it's all
made for online
right i'm not planning that far ahead
with starbucks good point you guys are
everywhere so i get a starbucks when i
pass a starbucks i'm not saying hey i'm
going to starbucks today that's not on
my [ __ ] uh to-do list at 6 a.m
i'm going when i go what is the upside
to doing it online
well you you uh you get there and it's
just there and you're in and out so you
you take away the
14 seconds of interaction with the guy
going i'll get the small here's my money
you're not waiting in line i'm not
waiting for you i'll tell you i'm
waiting there for like 10 minutes for a
[ __ ] egg sandwich oh
they're winning they're winning these
people i didn't know it was that it's
like crypto i know it's the future but i
won't bite yeah i don't like it
i'm with you
it bothers me i want to just walk in and
do it yeah
just grab their drinks well that ju
those jobs are going to be gone soon
those drinks why someone like well yeah
i mean there's gonna there's like six
people at starbucks they're gonna cut
down to three very soon right yeah
you're right
there's like what two cashiers
but they're very relaxed we're like some
guy will come in and just grab a
chipotle bag off that shelf and i'm like
no id how do they know that's the guy
could i just grab it
we know you would i know yeah i thought
about it
but you just don't want the sour cream
burrito or whatever that guy ordered
but yeah you're right i'm with you mark
i stole a shitty burrito
that city's gone to [ __ ]
this city is going downhill oh yeah i
mean i love it here but i mean matt
talking about having a by the way matt
you're talking about having a knife in a
recent episode my friend brought it up
to me goes does he know how to use a
knife no well he was like isn't he
scared that the guy is going to take the
knife and then carve him up instead of
just like hit him why else would carry
mace
yeah utility belt who are you
batman or batman
so i figured mace and a knife i'm gonna
win i hope i don't know man the mace is
is a good move although i have mace and
i have uh hand sanitizing spray and i'm
scared i'm gonna take the spray i'm just
gonna spray him he's like oh thank you
didn't we buy it the same day together i
have a bunch i got online i just i just
have a bunch you know uh with my
girlfriend in town i don't want her to
not have something on her so i bought a
bunch all these [ __ ] buying mace
online i go down to the mays shop
well i bought it i bought them in person
too but they did okay it's a two
uh buy limit you can't buy more than two
oh so that's why i stocked up online i
did buy in person actually but you also
have to give your uh driver's license
when you do it
interesting yeah
wow they called you from ace yeah well
they i want they want in the system so
you're not hoarding mace whoa
[ __ ] i it's i think other states it's
legal new york has a weird of course
like yeah in connecticut you can get it
and you're like cool no uh no guys
running at me with this dick out on the
train in connecticut
these are new york problems yeah some
guy's trying to sell you a schooner hang
on wait
yeah i don't know connecticut's got some
dicey at bridgeport bridgeport's dice
pretty tough uh hartford's got some some
sketch
new haven
hartford's definitely got some sketch oh
yeah new haven's got high crime rate
amazing food though yeah some of the
best food in the in the country the
little italy area is amazing
legendary they also the other ones like
modern which i've never been to but it's
apparently great and sally's i think oh
that's right yeah they said sinatra used
to ship that pepe's all over the country
yeah to vegas he would get a frozen sent
to vegas hmm there you go yeah dude it's
pretty damn good i'll give him that but
new haven you have like three blocks and
then you're you're in hell you know
there's not a lot of room there to roam
you're right it's not a walking city no
no even yale is beautiful looks like
harry potter over there and then you go
like one wrong turn out the gates and
you're in the wire whose joke was that
mark it was like the worse the
country is doing the better their food
is
schultz what was the joke something
about uh it's a good joke it's like
i don't i don't know if this is on any
special i don't want to you know give
out his material but it's like that's
not online somewhere the more the worse
uh the women are treating the country
the better the food is that's why no
one's ever said let's go out and get
canadian oh my god that's his punch but
i don't want to butcher it not my joke
but it's a good joke yeah
but yeah that's uh
yeah these uh that's that's america
though you go down one street and it's
new orleans is very like that you take a
wrong turn that's why these tourists get
[ __ ] up and that's most cities right
in america it's just it's crazy one
block's great i mean that's why it's i'm
always fascinated by people like
michelle wolf who like see cities by
running i used to do that all the time
but now i'm just i'm lazy but uh you run
and it's a great way to see a city but
if you don't know the city you're like
where the [ __ ] am i yeah yeah at least
you're on running
that's true
i have running i don't know i'd rather
walk
but i'm more of a walker too running is
just not
it's fun for a minute it's fun to get
your adrenaline up and i i get the rush
of it but it's just like
i don't know give her another ball right
basketball i'd rather be distracted
i i enjoy basketball so that's a good
cardio even the winter dude when you're
when you're like that winter uh
exercise where you're like
it's hard to breathe i love that [ __ ]
really yeah because when you're done it
feels amazing that's true it sucks for
like the first you know a couple minutes
but then when you're done you're like oh
that feels it feels so good to be in the
cold weather
not dressed warm yeah
and you don't need a jacket you're just
like oh i worked up a sweat i feel good
that's nice the head you get the head
steam love ahead steam love it now
what's you ever gotten runners high
that's the worst high obviously
you know of all the highs imagine
telling guys to rehab there if you have
to although the come down is way better
than heroin i think that's true that's
true i got it once in college uh i ran
forever and i was tired and i said keep
going and i felt it and i was like this
is runner's high and i've never got it
again i wonder if it's like lack of
oxygen or something
i don't know
yeah i think your brain's like you're
you're tired i know you're tired you're
still going so we're going to give you
another jolt some it's going to come
from somewhere well have you seen like
real runners the professional runners
they're kind of shredded oh yeah because
like well you don't think of a cardio
workout as making you shredded but like
i guess they're just breaking muscles
all the time or something i don't know
enough but like have you seen what's
that guy who's always on rogue and the
black guy who's a runner
goggins that guy's shredded shredded
because i think
like swimming for whatever reason like
everyone says that's a great workout
because uh you're not it's no impact so
it's all just cardio yeah but you're not
there's no impact so you're not like
making the muscles work in that way you
know so i mean michael phelps looks
amazing but like look at this guy his
muscles are so toned yes yes all
definition
also running is the only exercise where
you're allowed to [ __ ] yourself
you know i mean you always hear these
guys like i was running and then by the
13th mile i was [ __ ] but i kept
going and i'm like you can't really do
that in hockey
[ __ ] on the ice people are like wait is
that the puck you know but i'm just
saying you don't you only hear about
that with them
yeah hockey is so badass too i was
talking to uh you know i'm on the road
gary veda and we're talking about like
why are hockey movies so often the best
sports movies yeah and gary's like you
know what it is it's because a fight can
break out at any time and it makes sense
like it's good i love sports and i was
like that's that's well i mean why is
slap shot so [ __ ] funny why is hap i
mean happy gilmore the hockey scenes are
so [ __ ] funny so funny goon is a
really good movie miracle miracles great
true story yeah that's true hockey
movies are great mighty ducks was great
it's great
good call of eater yeah i mean slap shot
i mean one of the funniest scenes is the
kids
the handsome brothers go in and just
start beating the [ __ ] out of everybody
and one of the older guys on the team
goes this is a [ __ ] disgrace
paul newman that was a dark ass comedy i
loved it that was very like 77 you could
really get wild well there's something
about small market or like you know
triple a or minor league or something
because you
you're playing for the love of the game
yeah there's no [ __ ] right no one's
there for like the contract they're like
no i'm here because this is what we do
yeah i love that there's something like
very much related like hey man like
comedy's been good to us the last couple
years but we'd be doing this [ __ ]
if it wasn't good too that's true yeah
it's kind of the fun oh [ __ ]
and the cool
the cool thing about comedy is oh here
we go
like badasses who wear like thick framed
glasses
during the warm-up too
i mean it's hilarious if it dudes and
glasses you're like i'm getting my ass
kicked by nerds i know by the way
they're supposed to be wearing helmets
what the hell is going on here look at
this
oh i love it which is hilarious that
people just didn't want to wear them
yeah it's like when you see a dude on a
harley and he's just not wearing a
helmet and you're like you don't want to
have a helmet on nah messes up the hair
uh did you ever see that video it went
viral of the guy skiing by like some pro
hockey player and he's doing the rounds
in the rink and these girls are like
hey billy or whatever his name is i
sucked your dick in high school and he
was like oh yeah he looks up it's a
great moment that's hilarious so this is
a
goalie before they implemented the mask
rule for hockey games yeah
this is what these [ __ ] look
like yeah that's not good for your brain
no that's gotta suck and they always
have knocked out teeth
hockey players are [ __ ] cool dudes
though have you ever met hockey players
they're the best they're really good
dudes like because they it's a weird
combination of grace and also being kind
of a badass because even the finesse
guys are kind of badasses they still
kind of know how to fight oh yeah
equated to professional wrestlers also
really nice guys grace plus badass good
point but hockey i think you need some
money to start it so these guys kind of
came from a little money you can't be
broke and play hockey can you i think
it's a part of the culture and i think
maybe in america but i think in canada
it's very much part of the culture ah
okay okay because ponds freeze over
there and it's free yeah here you have
to have a ring but there it's free so
people can do it up there the skates the
pads the stick i don't know what pads
there you know when they're starting out
but i love uh hockey players are always
cool as [ __ ] like i used to have a
sports show and i remember like colton
orr was on you know who was like the
rangers enforcer and i'm like just i
remember he showed me his hands and i
was like this is i've never seen hands
like this this is real and i'd be like
were you ever just bummed when you had
to fight and he said yeah i'd look at
the calendar sometimes and i'd be like
[ __ ] they've got an enforcer on that
team who's going to want to fight me and
i'm going to have to fight this guy and
my head really hurts and i'm like what
an amazing way to live your life i mean
the goons are you know enforcers i guess
is the nicer way to put it uh yeah they
always retire young for the most part
sure [ __ ] heads are [ __ ] up
i mean they literally take they have
gloves on and they literally can you
imagine if boxers were just like
yeah i just started punching like mike
tyson just punching without gloves on on
skates too the whole thing's insane so
you need balance yeah
crazy about they pull your shirt over
just start wailing on you that was an
old danger show joke i went to a i went
to go see a fight a hockey game broke
out i love that show
i thought it was kenny youngman i mean
either way either tom green i guess he's
retired up to canada and he's living in
a cabin from the 1800s
and he's just this is so meditative he's
like just
fixing his hockey stick oh this is him
wow i didn't recognize him
he's one of the nicest guys great guy
and then he just him and his dog out
playing hockey on this road
i find that
insanely
anxiety-inducing this is a good
breakdown yeah i can break it in it's
all i'm thinking about i can't enjoy the
skate
well but that's if that's how you grow
up i think you get it a little more like
yeah greg fitzsimmons said he played
pawn hockey his whole childhood he said
it was the best thing in his life yeah
but i'm like i just can't not think
about the ice breaking yeah man you know
tom green is so talented he really is
like i grew up on him i really loved his
mtv show oh yeah he's super innovative
he was he's underrated as being like
andy kaufman level funny i think yeah
because i mean dude go to undercutters
pizza this is i think one of the
funniest sketches i've ever seen not a
sketch it's like real life but he
follows a pizza guy around
and he and it's called undercutters
pizza and he shows up with all the
toppings in the suitcase and he offers a
better deal
this is free jackass and free internet
peters can we play some of this on the
on the show yeah free funny or die
pre-adult swim
being weird
he's a funny dude yeah
look at this yeah what toppings did you
guys put on your pizza
trees extra chips ah i remember this wow
let's sit here no no we're from
undercutters how much is that how much
is yours get the hell away from me let
me get a paper for me though
cause you can get cheaper for me if you
want three seconds to get out of here
this is a new business
[Music]
give it to you cheaper
we're just trying to start a new
business here could have not done that
and then not have to clean all that [ __ ]
up
true
they spit on their own floors i don't
get it
i think it nailed it on the long island
yeah you know we just go up to where the
people
okay okay you guys ordered a pizza we
want to sell you got one for cheaper
let's let's go
let's go let's go
here we go
he was consistently so [ __ ] funny and
creative yeah and that that show was
amazing didn't he one time paint his hat
his dad's house plaid
something like that he always had a
wacky idea he
got uh testicle cancer
smashed the ball on air he did it on air
that was one of the most insane things
whatever he he had testicular cancer the
ball's removed he takes in a little
thing and he takes a hammer and breaks
it on tv with glenn remember glenn yes
and he was banging uh drew barrymore and
he married her married her yeah
this guy this [ __ ] geek good for him
my dad was threatening to to sell my car
the car that he bought for me
placing himself as a victim it's
hilarious yeah yeah you're supposed to
be nice though we're actually uh eskimo
brothers
who is me and green oh wait whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa no no no no no no no
we're burying the lead here go ahead
that's it that's the lead well who's the
gal well i'm not telling you the gal
drew barrymore
[Laughter]
glenn humble
[Laughter]
oh yeah green was great tv was fun tv
was fun
i mean he did the bum bum song it made
no some of this [ __ ] made no sense it
was amazing yeah the camera's on my bum
my bum is on the sidewalk yeah i can't
not look at your nipple when i talk to
you this is how i know i just you know
you can't either right no it's just
exactly round two well i feel
objectified what if i was a woman with
cleavage and you're just staring at it
i'd say you chose to dress this way
good point
all right mark just wants attention no
mark's good mark's gonna leave he's like
people were cat calling me i'd be like
what were you wearing
i was asking for it
oh yeah look at that uh let me give you
a peeve yeah hit me uh
what is this amazon it's [ __ ] itchy
but uh so
two i got two peeves i got more dew if
you want to keep going all right let's
keep going okay you want to hand over
the strawberries by the way
thank you
uh what the flavor of the champagne is
that right that's what they say i've
already eaten those reese's hearts
they're very good i love those dudes
greece is my favorite candy but uh so
one how about this guy the guy who asks
you a question
he's texting while you answer
isn't really listening then you say
something kind of interesting and he
goes what was that
i'm like wait
you you weren't listening to me now you
want me to go back because you weren't
listening get out of here
yeah it's like like we did open mics
we're so used to fighting for attention
i i got to do that off stage now right
i'm so with you i know those people and
you're kind of like how boring am i yeah
and then you hear something like wait
wait what huh and then you go what was
that part i'm like i'm not going back
you missed it it's tough these people i
mean these are the people who are like
on their phones while they watch movies
so you're like well how the hell am i
going to compete with that completely or
like the one earbud person like you stop
to talk to them they only take one
earbud out what's going on in the other
ear
you dazzle me i'll take out the left one
but until then it's a test yeah but now
you know i've been thinking like with
the iphone because i like to text too i
like to check my [ __ ] and whatever
so i get it i get look at your phone but
i'm like look i'm reading an article i'm
listening to a podcast he's talking to
me why am i more inclined to go to the
podcast than this guy talking to me and
i think i figured it out what you don't
have to react
with the pie you're just listening i can
do the dishes i can take a [ __ ] this guy
gotta go ah is that right you don't say
get out of here come on and i think that
doesn't sound like a lot of work but i
think it is yeah being present is work
being president's work our minds wander
so much we both you have 80d too yeah i
think so don't you think he has add yeah
he's all over the place he's all over
the place his podcast is called all over
the road yes
i mean very nice
oh hey what are you guys talking about
so then he you know i feel the same way
as mark though i'm definitely like i'm
like what the what
you know what i mean like oh yeah we
both do it yeah
i mean yeah when you're doing the dishes
or something and you're on the phone and
they're like i can't hear you what was
that you're like all right sorry i'll
just sit in my chair and talk to you i
was trying to do two birds one stone
here i get it yeah i get it too but uh
and look being present but you should be
considerate you should be you know
a human being and interactive but yeah
when you're with humans be a human there
you go that's the rule you can't have it
both ways yeah you know you should be a
human it's kind of like this
it's kind of like these comics who want
to stand in the room but still talk and
i'm like you got to talk outside the
room like but we want to see how the
show's going you're like you can't have
it both either sit in the room and don't
talk or get out of the room i remember
mark remember we were doing a club this
is
we were doing a club called uh seabees
comedy club oh [ __ ] it was a [ __ ]
remember that yeah it was like for those
who it's probably 2009 or something yeah
2008 it was for comics who didn't work
at the cellar yet so it was like me mark
normand
dan soder some killers named for guys
big j lewis gomez like uh adriana
palucci there were funny lineups
but uh i remember uh
you know were were there and mark and i
would like young comics just whispering
in the back and the guy who runs the
room was like incredibly abusive oh yeah
just [ __ ] with you non-stop but we
were like great i mean it was [ __ ] money
but they gave you a meal which kind of
for a lot back then good meal you worked
your whole day around you like i'll eat
at noon and that way i get the free
chicken meal and a's at eight yeah you
know and mark and i are just whispering
in the back and i'm like and then that's
happening and he just and the guy walks
over and goes shut up shut the [ __ ] up
and we're like well that was way louder
than what we did you know yeah but he's
just yelling at us right and uh and then
of course mark and i are like this we're
like ah and then he comes back and he
goes i'm so sorry i'm so sorry shots
shots we all just do shots
it was like the most incredibly abusive
relationship that mark and i were like
oh he likes us he gave us whiskey and at
the time i was like worth it
and a meal this is great oh we would get
ripped at those shows because booze was
like the only booze and food were the
only things free so you better believe
we abused it
totally totally used you you abused the
booze yeah sure even pass it on totally
it was fair all right here's another
peeve yeah tell me where you're at on
this one yeah and this is maybe me being
a petty [ __ ] but [ __ ] it it bothers me
i got a friend and we like to debate
that's like our whole friendship is
debating we love each other but we like
to come up with a thing and just fight
it out
and i got him i got him on this argument
i can't remember what it was and he goes
yeah you might be right like no no i'm
right
what might be you know
hey two plus two is four yeah you might
you might be right there no that's
it that's an objective answer that's the
best he can give you that's what it is
yeah drives me crazy or he goes uh
that's fair no that's not fair i'm dead
on here you've got him in a rear naked
choke tap out
you might have been beat here
yes you might have me here exactly hate
that you might be right we need to stop
these you might be there's too much
blurry [ __ ] am i right or am i not
right
yeah that's a tough person right there
that's a tough guy i don't know
maybe he's not that bad all right i like
him
um that's interesting let me see i had
other peeves i always have peevs i
always because of this show i always jot
them down when they bug me so i'm gonna
start doing that with my girl she's like
do i look fatness i'm like you might
have something
um let's see what else uh
oh i got one
i uh i emailed a guy about something i
would say hey i just need to know this
real quick and he goes call me i'll give
you the rundown like i'm emailing you
that's not even like a text to a call
email to a call you're jumping two
social levels here yeah good point call
me i'm like we're not close i just i
need to know an answer here real quick
yes so and these are always the people
that keep you on the phone for 45.
exactly that's what it is
i'm sorry you go no no you go i'm sorry
well no it'd be one thing to just have a
call and be like we're meeting at five
see you then bye but it's gonna be like
how are you what time are we meeting
i'll see you then can't wait looking
good it's in the calendar it's all the
extra [ __ ] all extra [ __ ] brother email
you don't have the extra you go beep
boop boop done
that's why the call sucks sucks it goes
back to the niceties of the uh the
listening it's the niceties that wear on
you
yeah the social norms yeah good name for
my album hey not bad it's not bad too
close to norm though yeah it is alright
p
oh yeah it's not you it's me
how about uh hey man quick rip to the
great louis anderson man because we've
recorded some of these late i love louie
anderson you're here i'm a big fan of
louis anderson
i grew up on life with louie same loved
it loved i mean i loved his stand-up i
opened for him once in vegas how was it
it was great he didn't love my act
really well he was like uh he was so
cool he took me out we went to
mcdonald's after how fun is that me and
him are at mcdonald's he drank milk at
mcdonald's which i'll never forget the
whole time i'm like what the [ __ ] this
gonna do he's drinking milk you know i
thought you were like a huge superstar
but whatever drinking milk and he's like
that one joke you got about i had that
joke about pedophiles where i'm like uh
girls go out and hit on guys just for
the free drinks it's a great bit makes
you wonder if kids ever hit on
pedophiles just for the candy and he was
like that joke's a little creepy i gotta
tell you it's a little creepy great he i
love louie anderson but he's incorrect
thank you but he's a clean comic so he
was just like i don't know about stuff
like that i'm like well the bit works
he's like i don't know but he was super
sweet he paid for the mcdonald's he ate
it all he ate mine
but uh great guy i mean just to hang out
i was nobody i was like an open miker
and he took me out to dinner and we
weren't open michael if you're working
vegas i guess you're right i i got a
lucky break there he did a great
five-minute routine on craig ferguson
about a hard episode he had and it was
the entire bit was going to the hospital
the entire late night set where he was
just like you know he's going through
all of it that was bleeding in the walls
in his heart and he's talking about and
he makes it so funny and you're like man
uh
such a talent he and he was a clean
comic yeah and it was very it was
weirdly like every man but also like
very witty and subtle it's hard to get
that combination where you you appeal to
like it felt like he appealed to
everyone yeah completely super likable
super down to earth and i believe the
first
fat guy comic i mean that's not true but
he really he i mean he made the fat
jokes what they were kind of yeah like
he kind of cemented that
you know let me move the mic stand so
you can see me like all those extra
jokes that everybody does now he started
it well as a late night as a late night
set you it's great to open with uh for
lateness it's great to open with a
self-deprecating question if you're fat
you get a quick fat joke out of the way
he had a great one on one where he goes
man what a beautiful day it was today
you know i almost went for a walk that's
a great opener you know it's a great
joke so yeah i love louie anderson uh
and i grew up on life with louie and
that was a great show totally i loved
him on family feud everything i'm yeah
i'm a fan baskets i never watched batman
oh he's great on bat and and kudos to
galifianakis for being like let's get
louie to play my mom hilarious and it
just worked do you uh
by the way you recommended the show to
me i i'm going it takes me a while but
i'm getting through to mark's rex mark
recommended uh bernie steambook i'm
watching taxi now because mark said how
good it was show taxi the show taxes not
the queen latifah movie i love taxes
dude it's phenomenal yeah i don't know
how it's like shows like this are so
much it's still my humor like i love
james l brooks yes he's so good at
combining funny and heart totally danny
devito judd hirsch i love it oh yeah
tony danza was the young heartthrob
christopher lloyd was the comic relief
and then kaufman comes in later
funny though dude dance is great i met
him at a broadway show when i was a kid
it's funny how the italians were the
heartthrobs in the 70s it was like scott
baio
tony danza john travolta it's all
italian dudes can i play this little bit
here yeah this is one of the funniest
writings on a sitcom ever
okay i'm skipping
taking a driving test
okay so he's taking a test and he's not
really prepared he has to pass to
continue to be a taxi driver lloyd lloyd
yeah okay so they're there to sort of
give moral support i love it yeah
[Applause]
why doesn't y'all like me
slow down
[Music]
i mean that's vaudeville right there
that's classic
slow down
that's comedy folks that is basic great
comedy
[Music]
he's going to do it
[Music]
[Applause]
imagine seeing that in 77 with your
family you'd be howling
[Applause]
[Music]
and cut
i love the the whole trope and sitcoms
where no one else hears things at full
volume i love it you know like what
should i tell my girlfriend and she's
sitting right there you know and they do
that every day tell her to stop being a
[ __ ] yeah just like doing her nails
yeah exactly i love dude uh
taxi is funny as hell
the pilot's incredible i wish spec shows
that like because pilots are hard
because you have to
introduce all the characters give a hint
of all of them make it funny and hook us
and they do all that i mean there's a
whole thing about how like your main
character is like you find out he's been
a deadbeat dad and the pilot and
he has to be likable
and they stick the landing like that's
like a [ __ ] play dude and you hold it
off in
20 something minutes like you know i
heard james l brooks once said about the
simpsons like no one's favorite
character is marge but she's the most
important character on the show
because
the fact that she loves homer lets homer
get away with any is that right that's
that's pretty interesting though right
like homer
he's most people's favorite character
yeah he's great at least of the may i
mean i love mo i love whatever but homer
does have a sweetness all his own for
sure but
but if he does shitty stuff in march
it's like you're abusing me yeah you
treat me like [ __ ] yeah there's that
episode
you know that's very interesting i never
thought about marge she's the glue she's
the glue how about you need that [ __ ]
yeah i would go same with cheryl on on
curb
uh not not she's not a marge but she
would keep larry together and all that
and you like larry because well he's
with her he can have a wife you know
somebody can stand to be with him it
gives him points and he is good to her
he's annoying but he's good too he's
good to her exactly like you think like
being mad larry we love him but like
being married to that character stuff oh
it's a nightmare totally
yeah he's the man yeah my ex-girlfriend
was like i love cheryl i was like yeah
cheryl she's not that funny but now i
get it you need her
in real life she's married to rfk junior
so she picks tough people in real life
too wait is she really yeah what yeah
and he sort of went off the rails this
week yeah he did oh yeah what happened
he just gave up oh you want to tell it i
mean go ahead i know jfk junior was like
a hunk is he a hunk
no he also has a raspy voice problem
anyway so
uh rfk gave a speech saying how uh the
people trying to give you the vaccine
are similar to the gestapo
and how in in uh
10 years from now with all this 5g
technology and all the
satellites there'll be nowhere to hide
even anne frank had somewhere to hide
it's like bro don't he also says that
frank was in germany he's just getting
bigger
also also the hiding uh did not work out
well for him i don't know if you
finished the book
but uh damn i gotta check this guy out
he sounds wild he's wild so he's a a
rabid anti-vaxxer and cheryl is a vaccer
there's christmas party where he's like
you have to be back to show up
whoa and he was like it's close to my
[ __ ] wife that was like in the invite
and then right after he's like he's like
oh i guess vax people can come here you
know
[Music]
well you got to hand it because larry
picked the right wife then because she's
kind of dealing with a guy who's tough
in real life too so that's probably
perfect casting for sure man i had no
idea i missed it all i did i didn't know
about this rfk thing what do you got for
a wreck well if we're going down the
comedy uh memory lane there with taxi
first of all the new season of ozark is
solid but i didn't want to wreck that
because it's too easy yeah so i i did a
little digging first of all i went to
syracuse this weekend
got my ass kicked by the crowd not good
well
we had five shows one show was amazing
just the hottest crowd ever and one
every other show was like yeah a knife
fight in calcutta just not getting shot
in that mall was a victory though that's
true that's true they had a shootings
did they recently yeah not that weekend
but that that mall has i'm gonna get
shot energy well the problem is the mall
is the city because it's so it's two
degrees so you got to go to the mall so
if there's a shootout in syracuse it's
at the mall you know everything's at the
mall the weddings are at the mall school
field trip shootings you name it yeah so
either way i was hanging out with this
kid kevin and he's like have you we're
talking about old jokes at at lunch and
he i did a dick gregory joke who's got
great jokes by the way great great job
killer one-liners he goes well you must
have seen the documentary and i was like
what there's a dick gregory documentary
yeah and he's like yeah it's on show
time so i went home and i watch it it's
[ __ ] great yeah civil rights activist
uh great joke writer yeah storyteller
health activist he was all about getting
rid of the war in vietnam he was all
about like eating right he would go to
like fat people's houses and help him
and stuff and he made all these uh
groups to help fat people and it was
fascinating he never stopped him
neglected the [ __ ] out of his 10
children
but a fascinating guy it's always weird
when people have huge families and
they're great to everyone but the family
that was big isn't that crazy that was a
big part of the duck yeah it's a little
weird you know because the kids were
like he's a bra a great man a brilliant
man but uh i'd like to see him you know
well yeah that's a lot of people who are
like historically great
talk to their kids yeah so true so true
i wanted to give you guys a wreck
privately but since we're here together
can i do this please yeah
so kamal bells has a
uh he's coming out by the way
oh really yeah yeah they got all the
black comics to talk he's got a dock
coming out i think later this week i saw
this on cosby oh you saw it already no i
didn't see the movie i saw the trailer
yeah you've seen this cosby it's so good
mark you have to watch this you've seen
the dock already no just the trailer
oh i'm gonna fall asleep halfway through
black man
stand up comic i was born in the
seventies
but this is more trouble for bill cosby
this was complicated
how do we talk about bill cosby uh-uh
it's complex come out you know
bill cosby was our teacher center of
morality all throughout his career made
my grandmother laugh made everybody in
the house laughs
hey there he is black america in the
20th century and not talk about bill
cosby
on that set i saw black writers black
directors have you ever wanted jobless i
was young
he was a pediatrician he was an object
that's right he delivered babies
oh my god he could have been a dentist
for crying out loud but you worry
bill cosby has been leaving breadcrumbs
this is my barbecue sauce
after people have something to get all
huggy buggy oh lisa bonnet he's just
talking about how to drug women
beautiful women they were lined up
outside of his dressing room what did
you think was going on he looked at me
and he said fool them again
often learn that you're heroes the worst
sorts of villains this is just a sad day
in the history of black culture it was
just like no
not bill cosby it's tough being a sister
even though it scares me you know now i
feel like i have to have this discussion
we thought we knew cosby we never knew
cosby
wow well it's nice to see this type of
conversation in long form and not on
twitter because it it deserves nuance
and it deserves because
you can be more than one thing and i'm
not look cosby's a terrible human being
but
but his entertainment did help people i
i do think like they're talking about
him being a teacher and like he didn't
follow his own example he was a dog [ __ ]
human being but it is important to have
that conversation in the long form
rather than you know in a click-baity
social media sort of way agreed agreed
way to bring it down
[Laughter]
yeah the whole thing is insane it shows
you like you never know like they were
playing a cosby clip on valentine's day
yeah ladies
ladies that's hilarious yeah last thing
i want to say about dick gregory
but uh one thing cool about dick gregory
good comic activist big activist but
still had jokes
you can be an activist comedian and
still be funny
folks out there you activist comedians
you still gotta have jokes like he would
go on the tonight show with like killer
jokes with a message but the jokes were
killer
i feel like you don't see that anymore
all these like raw rock comics they have
no no jokes i could not agree more you
know a lot of people you see them on the
road they're playing for people who
already agree with everything they say
right and they're kind of pandering to
those people of course so i mean it's an
easy trap to fall into but you still
need punchlines i think a good comedy
audience wants to be challenged not in
like some way like you're
alienating them but in a way where
you're kind of
everyone's not every joke but everyone's
while they're going hmm yeah what the
[ __ ] that setup is gonna do
i think keeping an audience a lot of
jokes should be the release of tension
and if you're just doing [ __ ] that they
already feel you're not accomplishing
that right right
a hint of discomfort is good for comedy
and uh
and seeing things from a different angle
like jeffrey jim jeffries aforementioned
the gun bit he hits every angle every
viewpoint every point of view and it's
like that's why that bit it went viral
he could have just gone guns are dumb
put him away joke joke joke but he hit
every angle that's what's great great
comedy is i love when a black comet goes
no no this is why racism is good you
know you're like whoa wait a minute you
know this is interesting now even yeah
sarcastic whatever it is but jim is like
it's almost with jim's bit on guns where
he is saying everything that you're
gonna poke a hole in like yeah who goes
and i know what you're gonna say i'm i'm
a foreigner talking about guns in
america i mean he handles it's almost
like you know
like he's a lawyer it's like a lawyer i
was just gonna like johnny cochran
say what you will oj did it but
he got him off and that's why we know
his name because he figured it out he
twisted it and got his argument out
there and that's why he's a you know the
legend that he is
same with a comic if you twist it and
you know tweak it you're like damn you
got a point
yeah stanhope is good at that too great
at it yeah so
that's fun but yeah that'll i'll watch
that but i feel like i know everything
you know yeah but it is interesting yeah
it's pretty well you don't know the
black perspective that's true that's
right and that's important you know i've
talked we've talked to godfrey about it
off camera and stuff and you know and
but that yeah it's tough i mean like
look we
we don't want to come off like
hypocrites we talked about annie hall
earlier today like i do feel like as a
jewish new yorker like that hit me
similarly you know like i loved woody's
movie so much so much a part of being a
jewish new yorker or just a new yorker
like manhattan is like a love story to
to new york oh yeah more than it is a 18
year old who goes to dalton 17 17.
whatever but uh
you know there's stuff that you have to
reckon with and and it's like can you
separate the artist from the art can you
not i mean there's a lot of
conversations out there with with bill
it's like his first album is called
himself
that makes it tough right he's like this
is me right
you do feel a little duped if you're a
bill cosby fan uh
it's stuff but then also you're like
well i think tom cruise is kind of a
kook too right yes and i love tom cruise
movies you know
it
where's the line um
and cosby's interesting because it shows
that it can go both ways you could you
can be this bad guy on cam like look at
jeslik cause whole jokes like killing
bait dead babies cancer jokes school
shooting jokes they're all funny but
he's a nice guy
cosby is the opposite we act like
because you you say crazy [ __ ] sometimes
you are a mean guy or gal but it can go
both ways you can be the height of
morality like cosby and be the worst guy
ever or you can say the worst [ __ ] ever
and be a great guy and if you feel more
duped when it's the nice sure sure
because you're like like i'm the nice
guy and then you find out that he
drugged 60 women there's 60 accusations
and you're like well those are the
people who came forward right i know so
that that's tough the number of cosby
victims is through the roof it is
hilarious to be that sanctimonious
uh well i don't curse in my act well you
do other stuff yeah exactly you did
other stuff that you know like i'll
curse right i won't do that yeah you
know so
uh
that's why it's so weird we're like
kevin hart made a gay slur 10 years ago
you're like well let's worry about this
guy kevin hart lost his opportunity to
host the oscars because he said
something
wrong about gay people meanwhile uh the
same academy awards
honored roman polanski in 2003 with a
lifetime achievement award so you're
kind of like well
i think as comics we're kind of like
we're annoyed with lack of consistency
yes right
no one's denying no one's saying none of
us are gonna say kevin hart's not funny
also we're all gonna say yeah roman
polanski's a great director yeah but uh
not just lack of consistency there's no
rule book this guy's punishment is worse
than that guys even though what he did
was different than what he did but he we
hate him now for some timing that was
good well timing to hurt that guy like
timing what are we doing here we need to
know what punishment fits the crime and
and with polanski's another one where
like nothing is more complex in that
situation he did something terrible he
also had one of the worst things happen
to him i mean losing your wife
to you know man oh right i mean if you
if you want to read a great book on this
the big goodbye by sam lawson is one of
the most incredible inside hollywood
books have ever really it is a wreck
it's i think i might have wrecked it on
the paw before but it's incredible it's
about polanski chinatown all that [ __ ]
it's really a good book
good nicholson stories but uh i wonder
polanski when uh tate died he was like
well she was getting old
all right
he liked younger girls
i'm trying to get a joke in somewhere
just lost your heart right we got heavy
he started it with his [ __ ] costume
oh yeah what are you putting we were
having a good time and then he shows us
a [ __ ] rape documentary
and i'm like what the [ __ ] are you doing
man good lord let's get the holocaust uh
film up here can we do that or there's a
pruder movie something let's just get
the bits then can we get uh yeah maybe
can we get like uh can we get some uh
ginger in here to cleanse the palate
what is a ginger right that's the [ __ ]
at sushi
do you want to can you show us a trailer
for an epstein documentary too
happy valentine's day everybody
boy valentine's hey how about the
memphis you know he's gonna have a weird
valentine's day this year julian maxwell
yeah it's got to be pretty weird yeah
[Laughter]
mark do you have a bit going down memory
jazlyn
yeah i got oh [ __ ] yeah what's my bid
what's my bit
this week big papa i know i got
something cooking baby doll
oh this joke i can never get to work and
maybe you guys can help me i think i'm
on to something but it ain't ready by a
mile
um
okay here we go
i've noticed uh like a lot of women are
very aesthetic you know their outfits
are well done their hair is done their
makeup is done their shoes are trendy
their apartment is well decorated they
got the mosquito net they got 19 pillows
even a woman's dog is well grew with a
little bow tie but their boyfriends or
husbands are the grossest thing in their
life
tend to be like look at salaccus he's
he's appalling physically you know
but like
they can see past that
where uh
you know like they can't see they want
their their furniture to be very perfect
like may my lady's always like we should
get furniture that matches the season
i'm like what we have a couch the couch
is the couch he's like yeah but what if
we got a couch this color because it'll
be better in the fall i'm like huh and
she'll buy different furs that go on top
of the couch depending on the time of
year but then she [ __ ] me
that's what i'm saying like isn't that
weird the thing you let [ __ ] you is the
grossest thing in your life
you know we're not very well groomed
we're sh we're we're unkempt we have a
little bo we got pubes you got back hair
that's my point is yeah like like a lot
of girls you see these beautiful models
and they're dating like uh you know a
guy with a beard long hair like a duck
dynasty guy yeah
so with men they can see past the looks
but everything else in their life is
very
materialistic the one time you break
your rule is on the most intimate
occasion right right i don't know if
there's anything here but uh
something interesting there it's
something i don't know that's that's my
personal thinking it's like yeah you're
like i need this spot
see i'm she's [ __ ] that might be the
punchline
[Laughter]
but that's making my point that's the
best part when you're like i was trying
to bit last night about like couples
therapy and it was just bombing and i
was like well i guess i'm the problem
you know
it was literally like yeah you're an
[ __ ] that's almost a good punch to
keep
um but yeah you know a guy comes
crawling out of her from under a car
he's got some [ __ ] oil grease right
here he's eating a hoagie drinking a
budweiser and well some woman's like oh
he's so manly yeah and she's into it
but yet the goddamn mosquito net around
the bed and the flower petals and the
the shawl and the furs and the pillows
they're all very manicured and perfect
mm-hmm yeah so what i'm trying to think
of what you're trying to say is it like
yeah because right now i already know
what you're trying to say is that
you're the one exception to her rule
exactly and the most important thing not
the most important thing in her life you
know the like you can buy a couch but
you you are in love with this man
and yet it's appalling it's gross to me
it's kind of like well if a guy is too
manicured he's either gay or he's in
love with himself oh so there's like
you're like you don't want a guy who's
that uh well taken care of
right
right
yeah
also the other the way to kill this bit
is by saying
well men have personalities and feelings
and these are just things
women
yeah women care what we're going to say
man i say that uh it's opposite for men
men will keep the place sloppy but want
the woman looking perfect we're the
opposite here we're the exact opposite
did you say that already kind of yeah i
thought of that but
now i'm doing men and women are
different bit kind of but i
i don't just i've we're also like
yeah i'm gonna [ __ ] you because i i want
you to look good because i'm also
[ __ ] you but they're like well i'm
[ __ ] you and you don't have to look
good
so it's interesting but they do want you
to look they want you to look somewhat
good yeah you can't be homeless but
yeah i just find interesting that the
thing they're [ __ ] they don't it's
gross looks aren't always the most
important thing to a woman with men with
men
but everything else in their life has
got to look perfect
and then you meet a woman who's got a
really messy apartment you're like oh
i'm not touching this one like there's
something about like you you want it
that way
yeah
yeah even women like paris hilton will
buy the dog that matches her it's cute
you know it's not like a uh you never
see a woman with like a dirty doverman
with like saliva and [ __ ]
but the boyfriend looks like [ __ ] mm-hmm
yeah i don't know where the i don't know
where the turn is i just find that
interesting
and i did this i told michelle wolf and
she was like this is big this is a bit
and i'm like i got nothing
also when someone tells you this is a
big bit it puts the pressure on i can't
think of it it resonates with women yes
yeah because you know you see you go
down women's track record and you're
like really that guy and they like dad
bods they're kind of into dad buds they
like hairy chest they like these things
about men i'm trying to think what mixes
it up right like if you're just doing if
you're only doing
one thing it's almost like adds
flavor
where it's
trying to find the right way to say this
yeah yeah i'm not adding much yet uh
like a woman wouldn't drive a hooptie
piece of [ __ ] car but she would date a
hoopty guy
i guess a hoopty guy can have it have
charm a personality a car can't really i
think if a guy though is too into
himself he's got nothing else to give
that he's all about him maybe she's
that's a red flag i think that might be
the angle well she fixed all these
things in her life to suit what she
likes maybe she thinks she'll fix the
guy too yeah well they do that's
definitely a thing yeah i mean i mean
that's why women a lot of women do try
to
get a fixer-upper i mean that's just
like having a good eye you look at the
apartment that you're like well this is
below market value but a renovation
could really make this yeah flip this
boyfriend okay now we're getting
somewhere yeah
all right okay
i like it maybe the house comparison
this has got good bones yes yes it's got
character
character goes a long way yeah that's a
charming [ __ ] pig
what movie
pulp fiction thank you all right what do
you got you got it all right what do you
got sorry that was that have i run the
bit about abc's what would you do by you
have you seen this show it's basically
if you haven't seen it it's like uh woke
punk'd
what you haven't seen this show abc's
what would you do what would you do oh
yeah i'm sorry yeah it's basically like
you get actors and then john cannonis
john there we go you know the guy is no
one knows him that's why this bit's been
kind of working out of the gate but it
needs more but like
so
they it's usually like a social justice
scenario they try to set up
where
they gauge the reaction of the people in
the store like the one i saw recently
there's always a click baity wanted like
one of them will be like you know
military guy with head problems after
the war uh gets made fun of by waitress
and you're like i mean who the [ __ ]
not gonna say something like it's only
saw that clip right so it's [ __ ] like
that or like there's one where like i
just saw recently and it's like a
woman's trying to buy a wedding dress
and the person selling it to her is like
you're a lesbian and that's disgusting
so we're not selling you the dress and
of course people in the stores are like
what the [ __ ] are you what's wrong with
you so basically test to see who will
speak up got it got it
yeah so there's a black mother daughter
who walk over to this woman they go this
is disgusting this is no different than
doing it to us because we're uh we're
black this is bigotry and they get so
worked up that they start crying
and it's like a heavy scene and then the
guy just comes out like
you're like that what why would you do
this you're just making people sad and
so my angle was like uh
he's not even famous the guy it's like
when you when it's ashton kutcher who
did it to you you're like oh cool i got
to meet a celebrity but he comes out
he's like it's me john quinones and
everyone in the store is like who yeah
is he like a fat hispanic guy yes yeah i
know that guy he's an older guy he's got
to be like 70. yeah and it's like aren't
you a little old for this [ __ ] dude all
right so that part kind of hits and then
i want to do a thing about like i'm
trying to add to it we're like
there's one scenario where it's like a
child who gets
she gets yeah look at him
he's kind of adorable he is but but she
gets kidnapped by another guy oh my god
yeah and she's an actress i mean i know
but you're setting up a real life and
death scenario yeah people are supposed
to jump into yeah yeah and then uh and
so my first off my my angle is like not
exactly a dream gig for this actor you
know ah he's like he's like wanted to be
hamlet
and uh he's like i'm i'm throwing a
seven-year-old into a windowless van
i'm trying to think i'm trying to wrap
it together somehow where it's like
you know one time people help and that
one time has got to be [ __ ]
terrifying for that actor yeah
you know what i mean where he's like uh
he's like where the [ __ ] is john
quinones guys
getting chased by the hell's angels here
right
right yes it's doing all right it needs
more something's off about it i don't
know well maybe the question is how far
is he willing to go like a lady at a
wedding shop is like
you won't serve her or because she's a
lesbian or whatever you won't sell to
her this is sad but
like what if we go all in like 9 11. now
we got a plane hitting a building and
then and then people are helping people
out of the building and some people run
and john quinones runs next to you sir
so you helped out you helped that old
lady out and like yeah the building's
fine they're like yes this was all a
game yeah yeah exactly how far is he
willing that's the angle you're right
that's that's the angle i have to push
it how far are we going to take this
[ __ ] that's that's the turn there we go
extreme like when does john can you just
intervene
yes yeah yes
then it's awkward because these are
serious situations so like
you know you ever seen the movie room
oh it's brutal i'm brutal but the girls
are trapped in the room and then jonas
walks in he's like six months later
isn't this crazy
like i've been driving real free yeah
exactly that's so that's great stuff and
i like how they're always in new jersey
like every one of them is in new jersey
like that's as far as they could take
the film crew it's like can we jump
somewhere else oh dude it's hilarious
you get like stan there's one i saw
where there's like two girls and they're
both with their grandma and of course
they're all actors and the grandmas are
like taking selfies in the in the diner
that was the whole thing that they're
embarrassing the kids they're like
you know gray hair don't care you know
instagram and they're like grandma
you're embarrassing us like you wish
they would just take it further and just
start like making out like grandma
when they turn to a guy they're like are
you embarrassing are you are you
embarrassed for them too and it's like a
staten island guy he's like i think your
[ __ ] grandmas are cool you know i
like your grandma
great i don't care that's what i say
about my pubes
but we got to wrap this up
coming in road gigs coming up mark where
you going to be man i'm all over the
place all over the road la jolla
california columbus ohio
cincinnati ohio
kentucky i think louisville
uh raleigh at the carolina theater
uh theater yeah we got some fun gigs
there tampa side splitters indianapolis
helium
um i think i got omaha nebraska
marketromancomedy.com check it out check
out my patreon for other stuff and uh
yeah yeah out to lunch netflix what do
you got fatty uh i got uh [ __ ] what do
we have uh february we have uh oh we
just passed this probably just past uh
hartford three i got sacramento this
weekend la jolla california at uh the
comedy store
uh we got orlando west palm columbus
salt lake city cleveland uh new york
city beacon theater baby those are those
are moving quickly we're going to sell
that out nashville tennessee
uh albany
[ __ ] all over the place toronto
buffalo
uh tampa yamada some [ __ ] check out
my youtube stuff you're all wonderful
people uh email us that we might be
drunk at gmail.com racks peeves
drinks
whatever the hell you want to talk about
[ __ ] we'll listen to our patreon is
patreon.com we might be drunk pod it's
killer oh i like this outro we might
need a jazz intro i know you guys hate
our our theme so
i like this type of [ __ ] if you got a
good jazz song we'll listen maybe
lyric-less yes lyric-less good call we
love you happy valentine's day
hope you stay together on your left sam
huh
oh
that is a
beautydrunk.compod.com and we have the
other ones too we have the rick and
morty one right oh yeah that's my
favorite one the rick and morty that's
killer here let me cover up my nip will
ya it's getting cold in here
cut glass but thank you guys and we'll
see you next week happy vale
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
you